the city of las vegas and southern  nevada health district are teaming up  for a handful of pop-up vaccine clinics  this week  you can get inoculated at las vegas fire  station two on durango  the gary reese freedom park and the  doolittle senior center you see the  dates and locations there on your screen  for more information on all the  coronavirus vaccine locations in the  valley  just head to eight newsnow dot com one  of those vaccine locations  area 15 which will look to vaccinate you  if you'd like  it is held in vaccines after dark  tonight from 7 to 10.  they'll offer the pfizer and the johnson  and johnson one-shot vaccine  people who get the medicine there you  also get free ice cream  and discounts to some of the experiences  inside the very unique  area 15.